unfortunately deaths on our Valley
roadways is nothing new but Nevada state
police are making their presence known
marking their joining forces pedestrian
safety campaign today 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough spoke with
the roadway safety Advocate and state
trooper to get the lowdown on current
numbers out there
as a driver you might get an offender
Bender for that being comfortable as a
pedestrian you lose your life Aaron
Breen road safety Advocate met up with
us near nhp's southern area command
breaking down fatality numbers as a
Nevada State Police has joined forces
with other law enforcement to stop
pedestrian fatalities in 2021 we had 65
and that is official so we had 65
fatalities which means we were up last
year we were incredibly up in bicyclists
each month Nevada State Police focuses
on specific topics to reduce fatalities
from distracted driving to speeding to
impairment and now until June 24th focus
is pedestrian safety we have seen a
spike in our fatality numbers and
we are very alarmed by it from April I
can tell you that in the state of Nevada
we have had 107 fatalities and 33 of
those fatalities were due to pedestrians
and just last month nhp reported 12
crashes which resulted in 14 fatalities
just in the southern area command they
haven't seen numbers that high since
2020. to put those numbers into
perspective May of last year nhp saw two
crashes with three fatalities Trooper
Wellman says pedestrian safety is a
two-way street as pedestrians and
drivers need to be aware of each other
while out on our roadways you know it's
summertime now we're going to see an
increase in our tourism we want people
to come to Las Vegas have a good time
just do it safely that's all we ask
out of the 107 deaths this year top
contributing factors include speed and
impairment 20 of those fatalities belong
to those not wearing seat belts